[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جمول
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من انطاكيا في ولايه هاتاي احدى
ولايتين تركيتين تستمر فيهما عمليات البحث
عن ناجين بعد اسبوعين من زلزال السادس من
الشهر
ومن اعزاز في حلب الشمالي هذه الصور
تاتينا مع استمرار الجهود الرامي لتوفير
مساكن مؤقته للمتضررين من الزلزال الذي
يدخل غدا الاثنين اسبوعه الثالث
ه نختم هذه الجوله المصوره بعيده اختتام
القمه الافريقيه السادسه
البيان الختامي للقمه جدد التشديد على
ضروره اقامه منطقه تجاره حره في افريقيا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
بعد اسبوعين على زلزال تركيا وقف عمليات
البحث عن ناجين محتملين في معظم الولايات
باستثنائها تاي وكرمان مراش وبالتزامن مع
اول زياره لبنك الى تركيا مساعدات اضافيه
امريكيه بمئه مليون دولار
للمتضررين من الكارثه واطباء بلا حدود
ترسم صوره قاتمه عن الاوضاع في شمال غربي
سوريا وتدعو الى زياده عاجله للمساعدات
[موسيقى]
بعد هجوم صاروخي قرب مجمع امني في وسط
العاصمه السوريه دمشق تتهم اسرائيل وتطالب
بتحرك دولي لوقف اعتداءاتها وطهران تندد
تل ابيب تلتزم الصمت رسميا نتنياهو يشدد
على عدم السماح لايران بالتمركز قرب حدود
اسرائيل الشماليه
بعد احتجاجات نقابيه
تصاعد المواجهه بين الرئيس والنقابات
الاتحاد العام للشغل يقول انه لن يقف
محايدا في الدفاع عن الحريات النقابيه
والفرديه والعامه ويهاجم قرار الرئاسه
التونسيه فرض الامينه العامه للنقابات
الاوروبيه
في ختام قمه الاتحاد الافريقي منطقه
التجاره الحره اولويه استراتيجيه دول
القاره تتقاسم القلق بشان الامن في منطقه
الساحل وتمول عمليات جديده لحفظ السلام
ومع الضجه التي اثارها طرد الدبلوماسيه
اسرائيليه رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
يؤكد عدم دعوه اي مسؤول وان وضع اسرائيل
كمراقب معلق منذ عام
وتهديدات متبادله
دعما عسكريا لروسيا او ساعدتها في الافلات
من العقوبات لجين تحذر واشنطن من العواقب
ومقابل تدريبات جويه امريكيه مشتركه مع
كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان مناورات بحريه
تجمع القوات الصينيه والروسيه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تفاعلات قضيه طرد
الدبلوماسيه الاسرائيليه شارون بارلي من
قمه الاتحاد الافريقي في اديس ابابا الحزب
الحاكم في جنوب افريقيا رحب بقرار الطرد
وقال انه احبط محاوله لمنع القمه من النظر
في تقرير تنطلق منه نقاشات حول ما اذا كان
ينبغي منحو اسرائيل صفه مراقب وقالت
الرئاسه في جنوب افريقيا ان على اسرائيل
اثبات ان جنوب افريقيا
والجزائر وراء طرد بارلي باعاز من ايران
المناطقه باسم رئيس المفوضيه مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي فقالت انه لم توجه
للدبلوماسيه الاسرائيليه اي دعوه لحضور
الاجتماع لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
برايكم في اي سياق ياتي طرد المسؤوله
الاسرائيليه من القمه الافريقيه ثمانيه وس
في المئه قالوا ان الامر يعزز المواقف
الرافضه لمنح اسرائيل صفه مراقب في
الاتحاد بينما قال 22% ان طرد المندوبه هو
نتيجه لحرق القواعد الاجرائيه للمشاركه في
القمه هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت
عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
في انتظار حكومه الانتقاليه في السودان
تباين في المواقف بين البرهان وحميدتي
ازاء حدود الاتفاق الايطالي ومصير قوات
الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
اعلنت هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه وقف
جهود البحث عن احياء تحت انقاذ الزلزال
المدمر في اغلب المحافظات مع استمراريه في
كهرمان مراش وهاتاي بعد اسبوع من الكارثه
الطبيعيه بلغ عدد الضحايا نحو سته واربعين
الفا في تركيا وسوريا واستدعوات بتقديم
المزيد من المساعدات للمتضررين
يرفع الانقاض املا العثور على جثه ايام
المعجزات والوصول الى ناجين ربما انتهت
رسميا قررت هيئه اداره الكوارث التركيه
وبعد 14 يوما من الفاجعه التي حلت بعده
محافظات تركيه اهله بالسكان قررت وقف جهود
البحث عن احياء تحت الركن لم يكن يسيرا
على رئيسها اعلان ذلك
اعماله البحث والانقاذ انتهت في معظم
المدن المنكوبه لكن هذه الاعمال ما زالت
مستمره في نحو 40 مبنى في كهرمان مراش
وانطاكيا مع كل يوم يمر يرتفع عدد قتل
الزلزال المروع لغايه الاحد بلغ عددهم ما
يقارب واحد واربعين الفا ووفق نائب الرئيس
التركي وخمسه الاف مبنى انهارت او تضررت
بشده وستهدم
هذه هاتاي بعد ان حولتها الهزه الارضيه
القويه الى اطلال من سيبقى فيها بعد الان
كثر قرروا مغادرتها باتجاه اضنه او مرسين
او مدن تركيه تبعد مئات الكيلومترات لكن
بعضهم يفضل البقاء حتى وهي في هذه الحاله
اجاب احدهم عندما سالوه هل سترحل قائلا
انطاكيا مدينه دمرت سبعه عشره مره في
تاريخها وسنعيد بنائها للمره الثامنه عشره
تحمل السلطات البلاد بعض المقاولين
المسؤوليه عن الخسائر البشريه والماديه
للكارثه الطبيعيه اعتقلت عشرات منهم بتهمه
التلاعب بالمواد وعدم الالتزام بمعايير
البناء المقاوم للزلازل من السماء وعلى
الارض عن قرب ثلاثه مشاهد تفرض نفسها
بمراره الركام وخيم الناجين والمقابر
الجماعيه للضحايا ديار بكر كهرماش اديما
ملاطيا هاتاي مساحات شاسعه في هذه المناطق
تحولت الى مثو اخير لعائلات بكاملها الف
العائلات باتاملها الوحيد هو العثور على
جثه قريب ليكون له قبر وشاهد يحمل اسمه
قائمه المقاس طويله يخشى مسؤول والصحه
انتشار الامراض المعديه بعد تضرر البنيه
التحتيه للصرف الصحي ترجح تقديرات منظمه
الصحه العالميه ان نحو 25 مليون شخص بحاجه
الى مساعدات انسانيه في تركيا وسوريا قد
لا تسمع بعد الان التصفيقات والتكبيرات
بخروج احياء من تحت الركام وقد تحتاج
تركيا وسوريا لعقود قبل التعافي التام من
دقيقتين حولت مدنا الى فتاه وقتلت اكثر من
46 الف شخص وتركت مئات الالاف في حداد
طويل وبنا ماوى قهر زلزال كهرمان مراش
كبير جدا
في هذه الاثناء بدات سلطات التركيه في
بناء منطقه اقامه مؤقته بمنطقتي نورداغ
واصلاحيه في غاز عنتاب اللتين تضررتان من
الزلزال وستستوعب المنطقه 19000 شخص
وستتكون من ثلاثه الاف ومئتين وثماني
وحدات سكنيه
معنى من مدينه اديمان جنوب شرق تركيا محمد
يشيل منسق اعمال تاسيسا مخيمات في جمعيه
حجر الصدقه الاغاثيه مرحبا بك سيد محمد
هل هناك ما يكفي من الخيام ومن البيوت
الجاهزه لاواء هؤلاء المتضررين ولو مؤقتا
نعم نحن نجول على كل المدن التي تاثرت
بفعل الزلزال نحن في اضنه في
لحظه الراهنه نتحدث عن احدى اكبر المدن في
الاجزاء الشرقيه من تركيا والحكومه
التركيه نصبت الخيام حتى وصولي المنازل
الجديده اذا الناس يمكنهم ان يبيتوا في
هذه الخيام نعم ولكن كان سؤالي هل هناك ما
يكفي منها حاليا بحيث لا يبقى اي
اي شخص او اي عائله تفترش العراء في هذا
البرد
اذا الوضع اذا الخيام كافيه الان الخيام
كافيه الان
والحاويات كذلك بالاضافه الى توزيع الطعام
هذا ما يجري الان وبالنسبه للمستلزمات
الشخصيه التي يفترض ان تتجهز بها هذه
الخيام خصوصا وان كل الاثاث او كل
المستلزمات قد اصبحت تحت الانقاد لهذه
العائلات المشرده
صحيح اذا ما نظرتم خلفي هنا على سبيل
المثال يمكنكم ان تشاهدوا
زودته الحكومه التركيه للناس التدفئه هي
من بين المشكلات التي حلت
وجمعيتنا هي تعمل على توزيع البطانيات
للناس وبعض اللوازم الشخصيه وبعض الاحذيه
ويمكننا ان نتحدث عن
2500 منظمه غير حكوميه بالاضافه الى
الحكومه يساعدون جميعا الناس التدفئه حلت
ماذا عن المياه وعن الكهرباء
اذا
نحن في منطقه قريبه من حرم جامعي نحن نسجل
الان هذه المقابله في حديقه
الجامعه والناس هنا
في هذا المكان ليس لديهم اي مشاكل مرتبطه
بالحمامات او على سبيل المثال بالمياه
الجاريه
طيب هنا نود ان نسال بالنسبه
للمجموعات التي تسكن المناطق هل كل مجموعه
في منطقه معينه ستكون خيامها او بيوتها
الجاهزه في نفس المنطقه
[موسيقى]
نعم اذا ما يحصل هو ان هذه المنطقه يصعب
الوصول الى بعض البلدات فيها هي في الجبال
ما الذي نقوم به في هذه الحاله نستخدم
المروحيات تابعه للقوات المسلحه ونرسل
الخيام لسكان البلدات هؤلاء يبقون في
اماكنهم ولا ياتون الى المدن ونرسل
المساعدات عبر استخدام توافات الجيش محمد
ياسين مناسق اعمال تاسيس المخيمات في
جمعيات حجر الصدقه الاغافيه من مدينه
اديما جنوب شرق تركيا شكرا جزيلا لك
وصل وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الى تركيا في
زياره هي الاولى له منذ توليه منصبه قبل
عامين قال بلينكن انه حزين جدا لرؤيه
الدمار الذي خلفته الزلازل في تركيا مشيرا
الى التزام بلاده ببذل كل ما في وسعها
للمساعده في جهود الانقاذ والاغاثه
وكان بلينكن قد تفقد مع نظيره التركي
مولود شاوش اوغلو خلال جوله بطائره مروحيه
الوضع في المدن المنكوبه التي اصابها
الزلزال في تركيا ووصل بلينكن الى قاعده
انجور في اضنه جنوبي تركيا ومن المفترض ان
يتوجه غدا الاثنين الى انقره حيث يبحث مع
نظيره التركي الدعم الذي تقدمه واشنطن
للمتضررين من الزلزال
اما بشان الوضع في سوريا فقال الوزير
الامريكي انه ايصال المساعدات من قبل
المنظمات الى شمال غربي سوريا يواجه
تحديات عده واضاف في كلمه من قاعده جنوبي
تركيا ان هناك محاولات من روسيا وغيرها من
الدول لعدم اقامه نقاط عبور اخرى
فيما يتعلق بايصال المساعدات الى سوريا
هناك تحد كبير التحدي للمنظمات ومن يقدمون
المساعدات هو الدخول والوصول تم تقييد
عبور مساعدات الامم المتحده عبر نقطه عبور
واحده هناك محاولات من روسيا وغيرها من
الدول لعدم اتاحه نقاط عبور اخرى الحكومه
السوريه قالت انها ستوفر ممرات عبور اخرى
للامم المتحده لكن علينا ان نرى ذلك على
الارض نحاول ان نعزز المساعده الدمار في
سوريا كبير وسنعمل على ان لا تعطل اي
عقوبات مفروضه على سوريا وصول المساعدات
هذا لا شك فيه
في هذه الاثناء قالت وحدات وتنسيق الدعم
التابعه للائتلاف السوري المعارض ان اكثر
من 55 الف شخص نزحوا الى الملاجئ ليضافوا
الى اكثر من عشرين الفا كانوا يقيمون في
ملاجئ قبل الزلزال بسبب الحرب
وكان موفدون من الامم المتحده قد تفقدوا
مدينه جنديرس شمالي سوريا لتقييم
المساعدات بعد الزلزال وتوصف البلده بانها
من اكثر المناطق تضررا في الشمال السوري
من بيروت معنا ياسر كمال الدين رئيس بعثه
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود الى شمال السوريه
مرحبا بك دكتور
وطبعا نود منك ان نتعرف اولا على واقع
القطاع الطبي والصحي في شمال السوري في
ضوء ما خلفته هذه الكارثه وتعثر وصول
المساعدات كما بات معروفا الى تلك المنطقه
[موسيقى]
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود كيف يمكنكم الدخول
الى شمال السوري ووفق اي اليه
في الوضع الحالي اطباء بلا حدود لديها فرق
طبيه واغافيه بتعمل على الارض في شمال غرب
سوريا ونحن قادرين على ارسال
المواد الطبيه اللازمه عن طريق المعابر
المختلفه يعني اليوم
استطعنا ان احنا نوصل 12 او 14 مع زر 14
شاحنه محمله
بالمواد الاغاثيه
حوالي 1300 خيمه 1300
معدات
لتعامل مع الطقس البرد في فصل الشفاء عن
طريق معبر الحمام
فبنحاول على قدر المستطاع ان احنا نوصل
المساعدات الطبيه والمساعدات الاغاثيه من
كل الطرق المتاحه حتى اختلاف المعابر
الرسميه المتوافق عليها طيب اذا بقينا في
الجانب الصحي
والواقع الموجود في شمال السوري شمال غرب
سوريا تحديدا لا شك انك تبعت التحذيرات
الامميه بشكل خاص من انتشار الاوبئه بعد
هذه الكارثه وربما تحلل الجثث تحت الانقاض
في وقت اساسا المنطقه كانت تعاني من مرض
الكوليرا كيف يتم التحوط من من انتشار
اوبئه بهذا الشكل
هو طبعا يعني يصعب الاستنباط بمدى انتشار
الاوبئه المختلفه بسبب
الزلزال لكن من خبره اطباء بلا حدود في
العمل في اوقات الكوارث الطبيعيه التدمير
اللي بيحصل للبنيه التحتيه والمرافق
الصحيه
يؤدي لزياده خطر انتشار الاوبئه وخلينا
نفتكر ان في شمال غرب سوريا كان في وباء
كل رف كان منتشر في شمال غرب سوريا وهو
وباء بينتقل بالمياه الملوثه والاكل
الملوثه للاسف لو الاستجابه الانسانيه ما
كانتش بقدر الكافي في المقامات الجديده
الناتجه عن الزلزال لو ما تمش توصيل
المناطق المناطق الصحيه المطلوبه المياه
النظيفه بشكل عاجل فعلا
بيكون في زياده رهيبه من خطر انتشار
الامراض المعديه في الاماكن الجديده
الوصولها سكان النازحين
شكرا لك ياسر كمال الدين رئيس بعثه منظمه
اطباء بلا حدود الى شمال السوري كنت معنا
من بيروت
مشاهدينا في فقره المتابعه ستكون لنا وقفه
اخرى مع زلزال تركيا وسوريا حيث او من حيث
شدته ووجوده على قائمه اعنف 10 زلازل خلال
مئه عام
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الصحه السوريه مقتل خمسه
اشخاص بينهم عسكري في قصف اسرائيلي على
احياء سكنيه في دمشق وقالت وكاله الانباء
السوريه ان صواريخ اسرائيليه اصابت ابنيه
ماهوله في منطقه كفر سوسه وذكرت الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه انما وصفتها بشخصيه كبيره
ربما كانت مستهدفه بهجومك فرسوسه في
المقابل نفت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه صحه
التقارير بشان وجود ايرانيين بين ضحايا
الغارات التي استهدفت الليله الماضيه
منطقه كفر سوسه في دمشق
هجوم صاروخي اسرائيلي موجه في قلب العاصمه
السوريه نادرا ما تشن اسرائيل ضربات
مماثله داخل دمشق اذ تقتصر غارات
مقاتلاتها على مواقع عسكريه في اطراف
العاصمه السوريه وريفها ومناطق اخرى فبعد
منتصف ليل السبت انطلقت صواريخ مقاتلات
اسرائيليه من جهه الجولان السوري لتدك
مواقع في قلب العاصمه السوريه دمشق
ومحيطها اصوات الانفجارات ونيرانها علت في
سماء العاصمه السوريه قصفت الصواريخ
الاسرائيليه بشكل رئيسي حيا كفر سوسه جنوب
غرب دمشق وهو احد الاحياء الراقيه في
العاصمه السوريه يضم حيكفر سوسه مقر امنيه
تشكل ما يسميه السوريون بالمربع الامني
وهي منطقه شديده المراقبه من قبل قوات
النظام وعاده ما تشهد انتشارا عسكريا
وامنيا واسعا يجاور المربع الامني في كفر
سوسه منشات ايرانيه
بينها مدرسه ومركز ثقافي وفق ما اعلن فان
القصف الاسرائيلي استهدف مبان في محيط
المدرسه الايرانيه في المنطقه ما ادى
لتدمير مبنى وكانت هذه المنطقه قد شهدت
اغتيال عماد مغنيه القائد البارز السابق
في حزب الله اللبناني في 2008 بتفجير
سيارته وغير بعيد عن كفر سوسه طالت
الصواريخ الاسرائيليه منطقه اخرى تقع ما
بين السيده زينب التي تشهد وجودا ايرانيا
لافتا والديا بريف دمشق نجم عنها حرائق
وانفجارات وسبق ان تعرض موقع القصف
الاسرائيلي لعده تفجيرات كان ابرزها تفجير
سياره مفخخه في محيط المدرسه الايرانيه في
يوليو 2016 وتفجير اخر في يناير 2017 قيل
حينها ان الهدف غرفه عمليات واجتماعات
لقيادات تدير مجموعات عسكريه مدعومه من
ايران لم يتضح ما اذا كان القصف
الاسرائيلي استهدف قويه بعينها فالى الان
لم يصدر اي تعليق رسمي عن اسرائيل التي
تتحفظ على الدوام عن تاكيد قيامها باي عمل
عسكري في سوريا وتكتفي فقط بالوعيد بانها
ستكبح محاولات ايران لترسيخ وجودها
العسكري في سوريا طهران نفت بشكل قاطع ان
يكون اي من مواطنيها قد قتل او اصيب في
الغارات الاسرائيليه على دمشق مؤكده ان
جميع من قتلوا في كفر سوسهم سوريون منذ ما
يقرب من عشره اعوام شان الجيش الاسرائيلي
مئات الضربات الجويه في سوريا تستهدف
مواقع للجيش السوري واهدافا ايرانيه واخرى
لحزب الله بينها مستودعات اسلحه وذخائر
يقول خبراء عسكريون اسرائيليون ان الغارات
الجويه جزء من تصعيد لصراع منخفض الحده
هدفه ابطاء الوجود العسكري المتنامي
لايران في سوريا
لم تعلق اسرائيل اذا على الهجوم لكن رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامينه ياهو قال في
حديث له اليوم ان اسرائيل لن تسمح لايران
بامتلاك سلاح النووي او التمركز قرب حدود
اسرائيل الشماليه حسب قوله
لن نسمح لايران بامتلاك سلاح نووي ولن
نتيح لها التمركز قرب حدودنا الشماليه
نفعل كل شيء لحمايه مواطنين ونرد بقوه على
الهجمات ضدنا
من تل ابيب اور هيلر المراسله العسكريه
للقناه الثالثه عشره الاسرائيليه اور هيلر
ما الذي استهدفته الطائرات في العاصمه
السوريه دمشق حسب معلوماتك
كما تعرفون ان القوات الجويه الاسرائيليه
وجيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي يحاولون ان
يكسروا الجهود الايرانيه في سوريا لكي
يستخدم الشعب السوري كارهينه لهم وما
رايناه الليله هو ماساه كبرى لان القوات
الجويه الاسرائيليه قصفت
شحنه سلاح ايرانيه في طريقها الى حزب الله
وكان هناك مضادات جويه سوريه حاولت ان
تسقط الطائرات
الاسرائيليه كان هناك صاروخ سوري اصاب
المبنى المدني في كفر سوسه في دمشق وادى
الى مقت الابرياء بعد هذه الماساه الكبرى
يتعين على الشعب السوري ان يطلب
بغض النظر عن
عما يتعين وغير ذلك نود ان نفهم يعني
لا نحتاج الى رسائل سياسيه الان نريد
معلومات بشان ما حصل ترددت معلومات ان
اسرائيل حاولت اغتيال شخصيه معينه لكنها
فشلت
وهجومها او
نيه الهجوم سربت الى اطراف اخرى فاخلت
المكان
كلا كلا اسرائيل لم تحاول ان تختال اي
شخصيه عندما تودوا اسرائيل ان تختال شخصيه
تنجح في عملياتها لم يكن هناك اي محاوله
اغتيال الليله في دمشق كان هجوما على شاحن
ايرانيه تهرب الاسلحه من خلال استخدام
الماساه
عفوا نحن نتحدث عن مباني ومساكن في قلب
العاصمه ولم يظهر لم تظهر اي شاحنه يعني
الصور منذ اللحظه الاولى
تم نشرها ولم تظهر اي شاحنه او اي اسلحه
استهدفت استهدفت مباني سكنيه
كلا ما هاجمته اسرائيل الليله في سوريا
كان
تابعا لايران وحزب الله اذا القاعده
البعيده من كفرسوسه في نتحدث عن منطقه في
الجنوب في السويداء وفي اماكن اخرى في
سوريا القوات الجويه الاسرائيليه قصفت
رادارات ساعدت حزب الله في جهده ضد
اسرائيل ويعتقدوا ان الماساه
نود ان نفهم ايضا نود ان نفهم ايضا ماذا
يقصد نتنياهو عندما
يقول انه لن يسمح لايران بامتلاك سلاح
نووي او
التمركز عند حدودها الشماليه ماذا سيفعل
اكثر مما يفعله مع العلم ان
المنظمات التي
توالي ايران او تؤيد ايران عمليا هي
موجوده فعلا على الحدود الشماليه ماذا
بامكانات نياهو ان يفعل وبماذا يهدد
كما تعرفون
في اسرائيل ناخذ هذا الموضوع على محمى
الجد نحن كيهود وكاسرائيليين ناخذ
الديكتاتوريين على محمل الجد خصوصا اذا ما
هددوا
بمحو اسرائيل عن وجه الارض ان
وكاله دوليه للطاقه الذريه اعلنت ان
اليورانيوم والمخصب وصل الى
84% في ايران الخلاصه الوحيده هي ان ايران
تحاول ان تستحود على السلاح النووي لديها
ما يكفي مليوريرانيوم للرؤوس النوويه
ولديها لربما سنه لكي تتمكن من وضع راس
الدواوي على صاروخ وقصف منزلي في تل ابيب
على سبيل المثال
لن تنتظر اسرائيل ايران لكي تقوم بذلك منذ
اسابيع وللمره الاولى اثناء المناورات
قامت القوات الجويه
هيلر من تل ابيب المراسل العسكري للقناه
الثالثه عشره
الاسرائيليه ونبقى في نفس الموضوع مع هذه
افقه من طهران الدبلوماسيه الايراني
السابق سيد هادي كما هو واضح يعني كان
هناك صحيح ليس هناك اعتراف رسمي ولكن واضح
حتى من خلال ما تبعناه من المراسل العسكري
الاسرائيلي لان اسرائيل هي من قامت بهذا
القسوه هي تستهدف ايران بشكل مباشر في
سوريا
ماذا عن رد فعل ايران
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لك التعايد استاذ
حسن والمشاهدين في الحقيقه
قامت اسرائيل وخصوصا في هذه المرحله التي
يواجه فيها الشعب السوري والحكومه السوريه
نكبه الزلزال وهو بامس الحاجه الى مساعدات
انسانيه على مستوى الغذاء والدواء
واستلزمات الاخرى للحياه البسيطه على
الاقل في المراحل الاولى
واستغل العدو الصهيوني بهذه الفرصه وقام
بهذه العمليه
الدنيئه الخسيسه التي استنكرها في الحقيقه
الوجدان البشري ولكن فيما يتعلق بالتفاصيل
انه كانت هناك شخصيه مهمه او غير ايرانيه
او قتل فيها او لم يقتل وكان تقصد شاحنه
كما اعترضت حضرتك عليه انه لم توجد هناك
اثار لشاحنه فهذه العمليه ارادت ان تخلط
الاوراق وارادت ان تعرقل عمليه الانقاذ في
الحقيقه ما يمكن الان انقاذه من الشعب
السوري
ونظرا للشحه بسبب العقوبات عقوبات سيزر
والتهديد الامريكي لحتى الدول الغربيه
التي اضطرت ان تنزل طائراتها في مطار
بيروت ولا تنزل في مطار دمشق فهذا هو في
الحقيقه حقيقه عدو الصهيوني استاذ حسن طيب
لكن يعني بغض النظر ان كانت هذه الغارات
قد
حققت اهدافها ام لا
يبقى ان ايراني هي المستهدفه ويبقى ان
اسرائيل ربما رفعت سقف التحدي بهذا القصف
في داخل العاصمه السوريه دمشق وبهذا العنف
الذي ادى الى الى سقوط مدنيين ضحايا وايضا
جرحى فضلا عن التدمير الكبير الذي شاهدناه
يعني هذه مرحله جديده من الغارات
الاسرائيليه
اسرائيليه في التصرف على حريه اسرائيليه
في القصف واستهداف ما تشاء ماذا لو عطفنا
ذلك على قول نتنياهو بانه لن يسمح لايران
بامتلاك سلاح نووي هل يمكن ان ينقل هذه
الضربات او او يعني هذا الاستهداف الى
داخل الايراني في مرحله اخرى ما دام لا
يجابه باي رد
كيف لا يجابل استاذ حسن يعني كل عمليه قام
بها العدو الصهيوني حتى العمليه الفاشله
ضد مصنع للتحقيقات العسكريه في اصفهان ردت
عليه ايران بشكل او اخر وطبعا مثل ما
تفضلت حضرتك لا تعلن لا اسرائيل ولا ايران
عندما تقوم بعمليه امنيه للقواعد العمل
الامني لا تسمح بالافصاح بصوره رسميه انه
نحن الذين يقولون بهذا العمليه او العدو
الصهيوني قام بهذا العمليه ولكن في
الحسابات الامنيه الحوادث التي
تحدث في الداخل الفلسطيني ضد المصالح
الصهيونيه او في اعالي البحار او في
منطقتنا المنطقه في الحقيقه في البحر
العرب كما حصل لهذه السفينه لا تعلن ايران
فليدع هو فلندع الاسرائيلي هو الذي يعترف
انه اين ترد ايران وكيف ترد ومتى ترد شكرا
جزيلا لك هذه الدبلوماسي الايراني السابق
كنت معنا من
[موسيقى]
قلل مين العام للاتحاد التونسي للشغل نور
الدين الطبوبي ان الاتحاد مستهدف لانه قال
كلمته بشكل واضح وهو مستعد لمواجهه الهجمه
التي يريد البعض انتاجها لتمرير مشاريع
بيع مكاسب البلاد حسب تعبيره جاءت تصريحات
الطبوب الجديده غدا ازمه مفتوحه بين
المنظمه النقابيه والسلطه واثرى تحركات
عماليه احتجاجيه في عده محافظات تونسيه
عقبها قرار الرئيس قيس سعيد ترحيل الامنه
العامه للاتحاد النقابات الاوروبيه
استرلينيش بدعوى تدخلها في الشان التونسي
ضجيج التجاذبات بين السلطه واتحاد الشغل
في تونس يعلو على ما سواه في مشهد الازمه
المستمره منذ تدابير الرئيس الاستثنائيه
قبل اكثر من عام ونصف
فبعد يوم النقابي حافل بالحشد الجماهيري
والخطب الحماسيه تمديدا بتردي الاوضاع
وسياسات السلطه كانت رساله المنظمه
النقابيه قد وصلت انها قويه وقادره على
التعبئه صحيح ان التحرك انتهى بترحيل استر
لانش الامينه العامه الاتحادات النقابات
الاوروبيه غير ان تلك الخطوه التي اتخذها
الرئيس قيس سعيد شخصيا بحق ضيفه الاتحاد
بدت عامله تاجيج اضافي خلافا ربما لما
اريد لها ان تحمله من رسائل الردع والحزم
الامين العام للاتحاد نور الدين الطبوبي
اكد مجددا ان المنظمه النقابيه مستعده
لمواجهه ما سماها الهجمه التي يريد البعض
انتهااجها لتمرير مشاريع بيع مكاسب تونس
وشدد الطبوب على ان الاتحاد لن يقف محايدا
دون الدفاع عن الحريات النقابيه والفرديه
والعامه كما رد على اتهامات الرئيس قائلا
ان حضور الامين العامه الاتحاد النقابات
الاوروبيه كان رساله دعم ومسانده لاستقواء
بالاجنبي معتبرا طردها وصمه عار ازمه استر
لانش هي فصل جديد في تلك التجاذبات لكنها
ايضا قد تكون منعطفا لطور اخر في الازمه
طرفاه المنظمه النقابيه والسلطه خاصه في
ضوء استدعاء الطبوب لماضي الصدمات بين
اتحاد الشغل ونظامي الرئيسيين بورق بن علي
خلال ثلاثه عقود مذكرا بان الاتحاد خرج
دائما منتصرا من كل المواجهات لا يعني ذلك
حتما ان الطرفين باتا على طريق الصدام لكن
المؤكد ان المنظمه النقابيه باتت تستشعر
اكثر فاكثر مخاطر الاستهداف لا سيما ان
الجو العام مشحون بخطابات التخوين وبحمله
اعتقالات واسعه شملت حتى الان شخصيات من
مختلف الفئات والمشارب لم يسلم منها
القضاء والاعلام هذا فضلا عن رسائل الرئيس
المبطنه الى المنظمه عندما حذرها ومن احدى
السكنات من تداخل العمل النقابي والمارب
السياسيه رغم ذلك فضل اتحاد الشغل دائما
النائيه بنفسه عن الاطراف السياسيه ورفض
اي تحالفات او اصطفافات تؤجج الاحتقان
الوطني اعتمادا على مقاربه به تقول قيادته
انها تتسق مع طبيعه الاتحاد كقوه توازن
مجتمعيه وعماليه محال ان تكون اداه بيد
هذا الطرف او ذاك حتى وان كثرت سهام النقد
من السلطه ومعارضيها
من تونس معنا احمد الامامي المتحدث باسم
تحالف احرار وايضا معنى من تونس خالد
البارودي الكاتب الصحفي سيد الهمامي سابدا
مع كان يعتقد الرئيس سعيد ان استعداءه
الاتحاد التونسي للشغل انما يكسبه شعبيه
في الشارع
شكرا لك وتحيه للاستاذ خالد البارودي عكس
ما تقول سيدي الكريم وانما الرئيس قيس سيد
ومنظومه مع خمسه ما بعد 25 جويليه هي
منظومه القطعه ما بين العمل النقابي
والعمل السياسي كان الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل في فتره عشره سنوات يتدخل في الشان
السياسي ويحظو ويقوم بالحوارات السياسيه
ويتدخل في الشان السياسي في البلاد الا ان
الرئيس قيس سعيد 25 جويليه تقول العمل
النقابي هو حق مكفول بالدستور ولا للمقارب
السياسيه كما قال الرئيس قيس سعيد اذا
فليكن الاتحاد العام
مهتما بالنقابيين وعماله واللي يخرج من
مربع السياسه هذا رساله واضحه جدا من رئيس
قيس سعيد مده يعني عديد المرات وكانت طرد
الامينه العامه للنقابيين الاوروبيين هي
احسن دليل لانه طب ولكن فقط سيد الهمامي
ولكن كل كلما كلما اتى
باحتجاج او بفعل الاتحاد العام التونسي
لشغل
بشان الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والماليه يعتبره
الرئيس قيس سعيد امرا مسيسا وبالتالي
يعني يصبغ علي الصفه السياسيه ويصبح
الاتحاد بهذا الشكل مدانا يعني ماذا يفعل
اذا لم يحتاج اذا النقابات لم تحتج في
الشارع او لم تحتاج بالبيانات كيف يكون
العمل النقابي اذا باختصار
باختصار شديد العمل النقابي واضح وعندما
يتحول الخطاب النقابي المدافع على حق
العمال العمل الاجتماعي الى خطاب موجه
للسياسه وموجه لرئيس الجمهوريه وموجه
للحكومه فيصبح خطابا سياسيا والسيده التي
حضرت في صفاقس يعني قدمت خطابا على ارض
الوطن التونسي العزيز
وقد عارضت وتدخلت في السياسه التونسيه
الاتحاد الان هناك تململ داخل الاتحاد
العام لانه لم يستطع تجميع يوم امس الناس
حوله
فقط عندما جيش كل هذه في صفاقس لم ينجح
ولا في ولايه من ولايه الجمهوريه تجميع
الناس حول
والنقابيون هناك يعني اصبحوا غاضبين جدا
على توجه ما بعد 25 جويليه نقول الى السيد
الطبوبي باختصار سيد الكريم نحن مع العمل
النقابي لكن ارجوك ترفع ودعم الاتحاد
الفكره اتضحت الفكره صيد البارودي سيد
البارودي
المطلوب ان يحصر الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل عمله بالاطار النقابي ولا يتدخل في
السياسه
وهذا ما يعارضه الرئيس قيس سعيد لا اكثر
ولا اقل تفضل
نعم مساء الخير في الحقيقه هذا كلام فيه
كثير من الخلط والخطا في نفس الوقت
الاتحاد العام التونسي لشغل منظمه وطنيه
مسارها منذ ما قبل الاستقلال ومع كل
الحكومات سواء مع بورقيبه او ابن علي او
حتى بعد الثوره كان دائما رافدا لكل
التحركات السياسيه وكل المطالب التونسيين
في التنميه في الكرامه في الشغل في الحقوق
النقابيه الاتحاد الشغل كان دائما الملجا
الذي تذهب اليه الاطراف السياسيه حينما لا
تجد وسيله للخروج من مازقها اتحاد الشغل
كان له دور كبير في الدوره الوطنيه وسواء
الثوره التونسيه وهو الذي انجح الثوره
اتحاد الشغل هو الذي اخرج البلاد من من
ازمه لكن في ظل الازمه نحن نتحدث الان في
ظل الازمه السياسيه التي تعانيها البلاد
وهذا الاصطفاف السي موجود بين الرئيس قيس
سعيد
ومعارضي نحن نتحدث عن هذه المرحله التي
تفرض على الاتحاد
الاكتفاء بالعمل النقابي كما يقول ضيفنا
ايضا
اردت فقط ان اقول انه لا يمكن فصل العمل
للنقابي عن العمل السياسي
لا يمكن ان نحصر منظمه وطنيه
طيله مسارها التاريخي وهي في تشتغل على كل
الميادين وعلى كل جبهات نحصرها اليوم
بالعمل النقابي هذا اولا ثانيا اتحاد
الشغل كان دائما وفيا للشغالين لحقوقهم
وما يقوموا الان هو عمل نقابي اتحاد الشغل
يطالب بالحوار الوطني يطالب بالحوار
المجتمعي يطالب بان لا يستفرد احدهم
بالقرار خاصه فيما يهم المؤسسات العموميه
وما يهمش شغالين الاتحاد الشغل يؤاخذ
الحكومه بانها تتنصل من الاتفاقات التي
اتحاد الشغل يؤاخذ الحكومه بانها وافقت
لكنه لم يستطع تجميع الناس وهناك تململ
داخل داخل اوساط الاتحاد كما يقول السيد
الهمامي ابدا عشرات الالاف من الشغاليين
من المواطنين العاديين ذهبوا الى
الوقفات التي دعى اليها اتحاد الشغل وكل
التونسيون يعرفون ان اتحاد شغل حينما ينزل
الى الميدان يجمع هو تقريبا اكبر قوه
للتجميع وبالتالي لا يمكن الحديث عن انه
لم يستطع ان يجامع اثنين الحديث عن ان
هناك خلافات داخله وهذا كلام مردود على
اصحابه لان راينا الضغوطات رئيس الجمهوريه
والحكومه هي التي ارادت ان تشوش على
المؤتمر الماضي وهي التي تصنع ضربه بعض
الاستفزازات بتعينات في الحكومه لاطراف
ربما
لديها مشاكل مع اتحاد الشغل اتحاد الشغل
يوم 25 كان مع
[موسيقى]
الجمهوريه اعتبره فرصه ولم ياتي يعني
معارضا له ولكن للاسف شديد الجمهوريه شكرا
لك هذه الاجسام الوسيطه ويرفض الشغل خالد
البارودي الكاتب الصحفي من تونس وشكرا
لاحمد الهمامي ايضا المتحدث باسم تحالف
احرار كان معنا من تونس
[موسيقى]
اختتمت القمه الافريقيه بالتصديق على
البيان الختامي والذي يتضمن ابرز
المشروعات والقرارات المرفوعه للقمه من
قبل المجلس الوزاري تناول البيان الختامي
قضايا اقتصاديه وسياسيه وامنيه عده ابرزها
تسريع تفعيل منطقه التجاره الحره
الافريقيه ومبادره اسكات البنادق لتسويه
الصراعات في اطار افريقي ودعم عمليات
التحول الديمقراطي ورفض الانقلابات
العسكريه وعدم الاعتراف بالانظمه القائمه
عليها كما اشار رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي الى اولويه مشروع منطقه التجاره
الحره مؤكدا ان عدد من الدول بدات بالفعل
مرحله التنفيذ
ونفى موسى فيك رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي قيام المفوضيه بتقديم دعوه
لاسرائيل لحضور القمه الافريقيه مضيفا في
رده على سؤال لمراسل الجزيره خلال المؤتمر
الصحفي الختامي للقمه الافريقيه ان مساله
حضور الوفد الاسرائيلي قيد التحقيق الان
وان الوضع القانونيه بشان قبول اسرائيل
عضو مراقب بالاتحاد معلق لحنبه لجنه
السبعه التي شكلت العام الماضي لهذا الغرض
ناقشنا العمل الماضي وضع اسرائيل كمراقب
في الاتحاد الافريقي وبعد هذه النقاشات
المختلفه قرر المؤتمر لجنه من رؤساء الدول
للبث في هذه المساله وهذا يعني ان الوضع
القانوني معلق حتى تفصل فيه هذه اللجنه
وبالتالي لم ندعو مسؤولين رسميين
اسرائيليين الى قمتنا لاحظنا شخصيه دخلت
القاعه ببطاقه دخول وطالبناها بمغادره
المكان ونحن نقوم بالتحقيقات الضروريه
لانها شخصيه لا تقيم هنا وجاءت من اسرائيل
ولا يمكن ان يصل احد الى هنا الا بدعوه من
رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي ونحن لم
ندعو اي مسؤول ولا حظنا ما حدث وسنقوم
بالتحقيق لتحديد المسؤوليات
وضمن اعلان الاتحاد الافريقي بشان فلسطين
استهجن البيان القتاني للقمه الافريقيه
استمرار التعنت الاسرائيلي في رفضه دعوات
القياده الفلسطينيه والمجتمع الدولي
لمفاوضات سلميه
وذكر البيان انه يدعم توجه دوله فلسطين
لتجديد طلبها للحصول على العضويه الكامله
في الامم المتحده كما دعى الجميع الدول
الى قبول هذه العضويه واعلن البيان الدعم
الكامل للشعب الفلسطيني في مقاومته
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي وادانا اغتيال
الصحفيه الفلسطينيه شيرين ابو عقله كما
اكد دعمه لاجراء تحقيق دولي مستقل للكشف
عن ظروف اغتيالها
معنى من مقر الاتحاد الافريقي في اديس
ابابا ابراهيم صالح الخبير في شؤون
الاتحاد الافريقيه سيد ابراهيم مرحبا بك
ما هي الرساله التي ارسلها الاتحاد
الافريقي الى اسرائيل اكان من خلال مضمون
هذا البيان او من خلال طرد الممثله
الاسرائيليه من الجلسه الافتتاحيه
نعم اختتمت اليوم كما
ظهر على التقرير
قاده القمه قاده
القاده الافارقه قمتهم اليوم
وفي ختام القمه كان هناك مؤتمر صحفي مشترك
للرئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي والرئيسه
الاتحاد الجديد رئيس جزر القمر غزال عثمان
وخلال المؤتمر الصحفي تم
وجهت الجزيره سؤالا حول ملابسات محاوله
محاوله ممكن نسميها محاوله يائسه من
اسرائيل للمشاركه وكان الرد واضحا من رئيس
المفوضيه ان
انهم لم يقدمون اي دعوه لهاذا الوفد وتم
رفضهم وكانت اشاره واضحه من ان الاتحاد
الافريقي لا زال متمسكا برؤيته
وتؤكد
الختام البيان الختامي للقمه الافريقيه
يؤكد على انه
يتعامل وفق القوانين او الاعراف التي اتفق
هل معنى ذلك هل معنى ذلك ان المعسكر داخل
الاتحاد الافريقي المؤيد لاسرائيل الذي
يسعى الى ادخال اسرائيل في هذه المنظومه
ولو كمراقب اصبح صوته منخفضا وبالتالي لن
تكون اسرائيل عضوا مراقبا في الاتحاد
تماما اعتقد ذلك وخاصه ان المحاوله التي
قامت بها اسرائيل للمشاركه فيها رسائل
استفزازيه لمنظومه الاتحاد الافريقي
والاعرافه وقوانينه هذه ربما تدعم الاتجاه
الرافد تماما وكما تعلم ان الاتجاه الرافد
وصل لنتائج متقدمه جدا وتم تشكيل
لجنه رئاسيه تتكون من سته رؤساء
يمثلون الاقاليم الخمسه
القاره الافريقيه بالاضافه الى نيجيريا
باعتبارها
حتى يكون هناك
موازنه في في الرفض او عدم الرفض نعم
يبقى سؤال متعلق بشان تماما انها كانت
رساله واضحه
نعم
طيب
يبقى يبقى السؤال للمتعلق بمنطقه التجاره
الحره بين الدول الدول الافريقيه
الى اي مدى بالامكان تحقيق هذا الحلم اذا
صح التعبير بين الدول الافريقيه في ضوء ما
هو معروف من ضغوطات دوليه تتعرض لها
العديد من هذه الدول الافريقيه على الصعيد
الاقتصادي وصعيد الانتاج ايضا
نعم حقيقه من خلال
المؤتمر الصحفي كانت الرؤيا واضحه بالنسبه
للقاده الافارقه حيث اشار الرئيس المفوضيه
ان
موضوع تنفيذ منطقه التجاره الحره هو موضوع
استراتيجي وبدانا فيه من قبل والان وصلنا
لمراحل المتقدمه جدا ربما عمليه التمويل
تكون احدى القضايا التي تحتاج الى
دعم قوي وفي هذا الصدد ايضا اشار الرئيس
المفوضيه ان كثير من اعضاء اعضاء
الاتحاد الافريقي او الدول الافريقيه
استجابت بصوره جيده جدا في هذا الاطار
اعتقد انا من خلال
المؤتمر الصحفي ومن خلال المؤشرات ان
القاده الافارقه
عازمونا على تحقيق هذا الهدف وقد مضوا فيه
مراحل متقدمه شكرا وانه اشار الى ان اكثر
من 46 دوله وافقوا على ذلك شكرا لك
ابراهيم صالح الخبير في شؤون الافريقيه
حدثتنا من اديس
[موسيقى]
توالت ردود الفعل بعد اول لقاء بين وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه ونظير الصيني
كشف بلينكن انه اكد ليوانجي ان بلاده لن
تقف مكتوفه الايدي امام انتهاك سيادتها
اما الخارجيه الصينيه فقد حذرت واشنطن من
انها ستتحمل كل العواقب اذا وصلت التصعيد
بشان المنطاد الصيني
اتجاذبات بين الولايات المتحده والصين لا
تقتصر على تداعيات حديثه اسقاط منطاد
التجسس فتنافس حاضر بين البلدين وحلفائهما
واصدقائهما في المحيطين الهندي والهادئ اذ
لا يكاد يمر اسبوع دون اجراء احد الطرفين
مناورات او تدريبات عسكريه مشتركه هناك
تحمل في طياتها العديده من الرسائل
لا يتوقف تبادل رسائل التحذير المبطنه
والصريحه بين الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
وبين خصومها ومنافسها في المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ فبعد نحو يوم واحد على قيام كوريا
الشماليه باطلاق صاروخ باليستي عابر
للقارات سرعت واشنطن لاجراء تدريبات جويه
مشتركه مع كل من كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
لكن هذا لا يعني ان هي المقصوده هنا فقط
فالقلق الاكبر لدى الولايات المتحده في
هذا الجزء من العالم ياتي بالدرجه الاولى
من الصين
وطموحها بان تكون لها اليد العليا هناك
ليس فقط في بحر جنوب الصين حيث توجد
تايوان ومضيقها وحيث لا تتوقف المناورات
الصينيه برا وجوا وبحرا بل وصولا الى
المحيط الهادئ حيث يتزايد الحضور العسكري
لبيجين والذي بلغ ذروته في الاشهر القليله
الماضيه
حاملات الطائرات الصينيه
قبل نحو شهر باتجاه جزيره غوام اكبر مركز
للجيش الامريكي في المحيط الهادئ
القلق الامريكي ضعف منه ذلك التقارب
المتسارع بين الصين وروسيا وتوسع رقعه
التعاون الاقتصادي والعسكري بينهما ففضلا
عن المناورات العسكريه الكبيره التي جرت
بينهما في ديسمبر الماضي وحلقت خلالها
طائراتهما الحربيه في اجواء بحر اليابان
وبحر الصين الشرقي فان كلا الدولتين
يستعدان للمشاركه في مناورات بحريه مشتركه
مع دوله جنوب افريقيا في المحيط الهندي
المناورات التي ينتظر ان تجري في الثاني
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري قباله السواحل
الشرقيه لجنوب افريقيا
سبق ان ابده الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي انزعاجهم العلنيه منها ومن تقارب
موسكو وبيجين مع بريتوريا
قالت المندوبه الامريكيه لدى الامم
المتحده ليندا توماس غريفلد لشبكه سي ان
ان بلادها ستواصل اجراء مناقشات بشان
تسليم اوكرانيا مقاتلات اف 16
واضافت نواشنطن تعمل مع كياد بشكل وثيق
ومباشر لمعرفه طبيعه الاحتياجات وتوقيت
الحصول عليها
اكملت بريطانيا تدريب عشره الاف مجند
اوكراني على اراضيها منذ يوليو تموز
الماضي تقول بريطانيا ان هذه التدريبات
العسكريه تاتي ضمن برنامج اوسع لدعم
اوكرانيا في مواجهه الهجمات الروسيه
مراسله الجزيره من حرب اللور فقط مجندين
اوكرانيين اثناء تدريبهم في موقع عسكري
شمال شرقي انجلترا
بالتقرير التالي
هذا واحد من بين مواقع عديده تابعه لوزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه هنا يتلقى المجندون
الاوكرانيون التدريبات العسكريه كثير منهم
مدنيون من دون خبرات
انهينا المرحله الاولى من التدريبات
التكتيكيه والاسعافات الاوليه واليوم
نتعلم المهارات الدفاعيه والهجوميه
المدينه الاوكرانيين الذين يتدربون على
استراتيجيات حرب الخنادق بهدف حمايه
انفسهم من المدفعيه المعاديه
التدريبات تحاكي واقع المعركه من متفجرات
وقنابله وتقديم اسعافات
نعلمهم المهارات العسكريه التي يحتاجونها
لتمكينه من البقايا على قيد الحياه
والدفاع عن ارضهم تقود بريطانيا منذ الصيف
الماضي عمليه انترفليكس لتدريب 20 الف
اوكراني وقد تم تدريب نصفي عددهم حتى الان
بمشاركه ضباط من دول حليفه تدعمه اوكرانيا
ومنها استراليا ونيوزيلندا والنرويج
نامل ان يعود المجندون الى اوكرانيا وهم
جاهزون للمهمه التي تنتظرهم وقد عززنا
قدراتهم على البقاء والنجاح
مع مرور عام على الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا كثفت بريطانيا وحلفائها تعزيز
قدراتك الدفاعيه بما فيها تدريب جنودها
على الدبابات الثقيله وهناك تعهدات لتشمل
التدريبات مشاه بحريه وطيار مقاتلات
مينا حرب اللغه الجزيره شمال الشرقي
انجلترا
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه هذا تذكير
بابرز العناوين في الحصاد الليل
بعد اسبوعين على زلزال تركيا وقف عمليات
البحث عن ناجين محتملين في معظم الولايات
باستثنائها تايوان مراش
وبالتزامن مع اول زياره لبنك الى تركيا
مساعدات اضافيه امريكيه بمئه مليون دولار
للمتضررين من الكارثه واطباء بلا حدود
ترسم صوره قاتمه عن الاوضاع في شمال غربي
سوريا وتدعو الى زياده عاجله للمساعدات
بعد هجوم صاروخي قرب مجمع امني في وسط
العاصمه السوريه دمشق تتهم اسرائيل وتطالب
بتحرك دولي لوقف اعتداءاتها وطهران تندد
تل ابيب تلتزم الصمت رسميا نتنياهو يشدد
على عدم السماح لايران بالتمركز قرب حدود
اسرائيل الشماليه
بعد احتجاجات نقابيه ضد سياسات قيس سعيد
في ثمان مدن تونسيه تصاعد المواجهه بين
الرئيس والنقابات الاتحاد العام للشغل
يقول انه لن يقف محايدا في الدفاع عن
الحريات النقابيه والفرديه والعامه ويهاجم
قرار الرئاسه التونسيه طرد الامينه العامه
للنقابات الاوروبيه
في ختام قمه الاتحاد الافريقي منطقه
التجاره الحره اولويه استراتيجيه دول
القاره تتقاسم القلق بشان الامن في منطقه
الساحل وتمول عمليات جديده لحفظ السلام
ومع الضجه التي اثارها طرد الدبلوماسيه
اسرائيليه رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
يؤكد عدم دعوه اي مسؤول وان وضع اسرائيل
كمراقب معلق منذ عام
بين واشنطن وبيجين سجال وتهديدات متبادله
دعما عسكريا لروسيا او ساعدتها في الافلات
من العقوبات بجين تحذر واشنطن من العواقب
ومقابله تدريبات جويه امريكيه مشتركه مع
كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان مناورات بحريه
تجمع القوات الصينيه والروسيه
اعلنت هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه وقت
جهود البحث عن احياء تحت انقاذ الزلزال
المدمر في اغلب المحافظات مع استمرارها في
كهرمان مراش وهاتاي بعد اسبوع من الكارثه
الطبيعيه بلغ عدد الضحايا نحو 46 الفا في
تركيا وسوريا واصطادعوات لتقديم المزيد من
المساعدات للمتضررين
يرفع الانقاض املا العثور على جثه ايام
المعجزات والوصول الى ناجين ربما انتهت
رسميا قررت هيئه اداره الكوارث التركيه
وبعد 14 يوما من الفاجعه التي حلت بعده
محافظات تركيه اهله بالسكان قررت وقف جهود
البحث عن احياء تحت الركم لم يكن يسيرا
على رئيسها اعلان ذلك
اعمال البحث والانقاذ انتهت في معظم المدن
المنكوبه لكن هذه الاعمال ما زالت مستمره
في نحو 40 مبنى في كهرمان مراش وانطاكيا
مع كل يوم يمر يرتفع عدد قتل الزلزال
المروع
هذه هاتاي بعد ان حولتها الهزه الارضيه
القويه الى اطلال من سيبقى فيها بعد الان
كثر قرروا مغادرتها باتجاه اضنه او مرسين
او مدن تركيه تبعد مئات الكيلومترات لكن
بعضهم يفضل البقاء حتى وهي في هذه الحاله
اجاب احدهم عندما سالوه هل سترحل قائلا
انطاكيا مدينه دمرت سبعه عشره مره في
تاريخها وسنعيد بنائها للمره الثامنه عشره
تحمل السلطات البلاد بعض المقاولين
المسؤوليه عن الخسائر البشريه والماديه
للكارثه الطبيعيه اعتقلت عشرات منهم بتهمه
التلاعب بالمواد وعدم الالتزام بمعايير
البناء المقاوم للزلازل من السماء وعلى
الارض عن قرب ثلاثه مشاهد تفرض نفسها
بمراره الركام وخيم الناجين والمقابر
الجماعيه للضحايا ديار بكر كهرما مراج
اديمان ملاطيا هاتاي مساحات شاسعه في هذه
المناطق تحولت الى مثوى اخير لعائلات
بكاملها الف العائلات بات املها الوحيد هو
العثور على جثه قريب ليكون له قبر وشاهد
يحمل اسمه
قائمه المقاس طويله يخشى مسؤوله الصحه
انتشار الامراض المعديه بعد تضرر البنيه
التحتيه للصرف الصحي ترجح تقديرات منظمه
الصحه العالميه ان نحو 26 مليون شخص بحاجه
الى مساعدات انسانيه في تركيا وسوريا
قد لا تسمع بعد الان التصفيقات والتكبيرات
بخروج احياء من تحت الركام وقد تحتاج
تركيا وسوريا لعقود قبل التعافي التام من
دقيقتين حولت مدنا الى فتات وقتلت اكثر من
46 الف شخص وتركت مئات الالاف في حداد
طويل وبنا ماوى قهر زلزال كهرمان مراش
كبير جدا
معنى من جناب توماسو ديلالونجا المتحدث
باسم الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات الصليب
الاحمر والهلال الاحمر توماسو مرحبا بك في
اي مرحله الان تكون
يعني جهود الانقاذ قد دخلت في ظل القناعه
بانعدام وجود احياء بعد هذه المده الطويله
من الزلزال
مساء الخير وشكرا جزيلا على هذه الاستضافه
مجددا الليله لسوء الحظ نعم كما اشارتم ان
فرصه ايجاد احياء تحت الانقاض شارفت على
الانتهاء نحن لا نزال لدينا امل ولكن
الفرصه تتضمن نحن نفكر
ب 100,000 شخص
بدات الكارثه بالنسبه
اليهم لقد انقذوا ولكن دمرت حيات هؤلاء
المدارس
الاعمال وبالتالي 400 الف شخص تاثروا
ونحن نفكر
بالامد المتوسط
البعيد نحن نتوقع ان العمليه الانسانيه
سوف تستمر لفتره طويله
الاحتياجات الان هي الماوى والدعم النفسي
بالاضافه الى الطعام والماء يعني الان
محاوله اعاده
هؤلاء المتضررين الى واقعهم الطبيعي مع
صعوبه ذلك بدءا من الايواء ما هو دور
الجمعيات الاهليه والمنظمات الانسانيه
والهلال الاحمر وصليب الاحمر على المستوى
الدولي ما هو دورهم في هذا المجال
في البدايه الحاجات مرتفعه للغايه
وبالتالي التنسيق اساسي لا نتحدث فقط عن
المنظمه واحده يمكنها ان تاتي بالحل
التنسيق بين الجمعيات والمنظمات هو ضروري
نحن نركز اولا على الماوى اولا لكي يكون
للناس اماكن امنه يمكنهم ان يبيتوا فيها
وايضا لاحقا للعوده الى الحياه الطبيعيه
طبعا يصعب ان نقول حياه طبيعيه ولكن في
هذا السياق الدعم النفسي هو اساسي باضافه
الى الاحتياجات الاساسيه هناك فرق وزعت
الملايين من كميات الطعام والماء للاشخاص
الناجين الذين بقوا على قيد الحياه نحن
نتحدث عن ماراثون نحن لا نتحدث عن سباق
السرعه نحن نتحدث عن فتره طويله نحن بحاجه
الى تنسيق لاشهر وسنوات في المستقبل مهمه
جمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر الان
في هذه المرحله الجديده من من مرحله
الايواء ومساعده هؤلاء المنكوبين اين
تنحصر مهمه هذه المنظمه الهلال الاحمر
وصليب الاحمر
ما رايناه في الميدان طبعا
الماوى الاساسيه والطعام والماء ولكن نحن
ندق ناقوس الخطر بشاني ازمه ثانيه هناك
اشخاص نزحوا وبالتالي نفكر
بالمياه وتامين المياه الجاريه
لهؤلاء الناس لتفادي الاوبئه والامراض
التنفسيه باضافه الى الامراض الجلديه كل
هذه الامور مهمه وبكل تاكيد بالنسبه الى
سوريا كما نعرف 12 سنه من النزاع اذا ان
هناك حاجه الى تقديم مستلزمات الرعايه
الشخصيه قبل الان بفتره وجيزه تفشى مرض
الكوليرا واراد ان اتفادى او بممثله
وامراض مماثله
شكرا
جزيلا لك توماسو ديلالونجا المتحدث باسم
الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر حدثتنا من
وصل وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن الى تركيا في زياره هي الاولى له
منذ توليه منصبه قبل عامين بلان كان قال
انه حزين جدا لرؤيه الدمار الذي خلفته
الزلازل في تركيا مشيرا الى التزام بلاده
ببذل كل ما في وسعها للمساعده في جهود
الانقاذ والاغاثه والتعافي وكان بلينكن قد
تفقد مع نظيره التركي مولود شاويش اوبلو
خلال جوله بطائره مروحيه الوضع في المدن
المنكوبه التي اصابها الزلزال في تركيا
ووصل بلينكن الى قاعده انجرلك في اضنه
جنوبي تركيا ومن المفترض ان يتوجه غدا
للاثنين الى انقره حيث يبحث مع نظيره
التركي الدعم الذي تقدمه واشنطن للمتضررين
من الزلزل
اما بشان الوضع في سوريا فقال الوزير
الامريكي ان ايصال المنظمات للمساعدات الى
شمال غربي سوريا يواجه تحديات عده واضاف
في كلمه من قاعده انجر جنوبي تركيا ان
هناك محاولات من روسيا وغيرها من الدول
لعدم اقامه نقاط عبور اخرى
فيما يتعلق بايصال المساعدات الى سوريا
هناك تحد كبير التحدي للمنظمات ومن يقدمون
المساعدات هو الدخول والوصول تم تقييد
عبور مساعدات الامم المتحده عبر نقطه عبور
واحده هناك محاولات من روسيا وغيرها من
الدول لعدم اتاحه نقاط عبور اخرى الحكومه
السوريه قالت انها ستوفر ممرات عبور اخرى
للامم المتحده لكن علينا ان نرى ذلك على
الارض نحاول ان نعزز المساعده الدمار في
سوريا كبير وسنعمل على ان لا تعطل اي
عقوبات مفروضه على سوريا وصول المساعدات
هذا لا شك فيه
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاثناء خلت وحدته تنسيق الدعم
التابعه للائتلاف السوري المعارض ان اكثر
من 55 الف شخص نزحوا الى الملاجئ ليضافوا
الى اكثر من عشرين الفا كانوا يقيمون في
ملاجئ قبل الزلزال بسبب الحرب
وكان موفدون من الامم المتحده قد تفقدوا
مدينه جنديرس الشماليه سوريا لتقييم
المساعدات بعد الزلزال وتوصف البلده بانها
من اكثر المناطق تضررا في الشمال السوري
اعلنت وزاره الصحه السوريه مقتل خمسه
اشخاص بينهم عسكري في قصف اسرائيلي على
احياء سكنيه في دمشق وقالت وكاله الانباء
السوريه ان صواريخ اسرائيليه اصاب امنيه
ماهوله في منطقه كفر سوسه وذكرت الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه انما وصفته بشخصيه كبيره ربما
كانت مستهدفه بهجوم كفر سوسه في المقابل
نفت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه صحه التقارير
بشان وجود ايرانيين بين ضحايا الغارات
التي استهدفت الليله الماضيه منطقه كفر
سوسه في دمشق
هجوم صاروخي اسرائيلي موجه في قلب العاصمه
السوريه نادرا ما تشن اسرائيل ضربات
مماثله داخل دمشق اذ تقتصر غارات
مقاتلاتها على مواقع عسكريه في اطراف
العاصمه السوريه وريفها ومناطق اخرى فبعد
منتصف ليل السبت انطلقت صواريخ مقاتلات
اسرائيليه من جهه الجولان السوري لتدك
مواقع في قلب العاصمه السوريه دمشق
ومحيطها اصوات الانفجارات ونيرانها علت في
سماء العاصمه السوريه قصفت الصواريخ
الاسرائيليه بشكل رئيسي حيا كفر سوسه جنوب
غرب دمشق وهو احد الاحياء الراقيه في
العاصمه السوريه يضم حيكفر سوسه مقر امنيه
تشكل ما يسميه السوريون بالمربع الامني
وهي منطقه شديده المراقبه من قبل قوات
النظام وعاده ما تشهد انتشارا عسكريا
وامنيا واسعا يجاور المربع الامني في كفر
سوسه منشات ايرانيه
بينها مدرسه ومركز ثقافي وفق ما اعلن فان
القصف الاسرائيلي استهدف مبان في محيط
المدرسه الايرانيه في المنطقه ما ادى
لتدمير مبنى وكانت هذه المنطقه قد شهدت
اغتيال عماد مغنيه القائد البارز السابق
في حزب الله اللبناني في 2008 بتفجير
سيارته وغير بعيد عن كفر سوسه طالت
الصواريخ الاسرائيليه منطقه اخرى تقع ما
بين السيده زينب التي تشهد وجودا ايرانيا
حرائق وانفجارات وسبق ان تعرض موقع القصف
الاسرائيلي لعده تفجيرات كان ابرزها تفجير
سياره مفخخه في محيط المدرسه الايرانيه في
يوليو 2016 وتفجير اخر في يناير 2017 قيل
حينها ان الهدف غرفه عمليات واجتماعات
لقيادات تدير مجموعات عسكريه مدعومه من
ايران لم يتضح ما اذا كان القصف
الاسرائيلي استهدف بعينها فالى الان لم
يصدر اي تعليق رسمي عن اسرائيل التي تتحفظ
على الدوام عن تاكيد قيامها باي عمل عسكري
في سوريا وتكتفي فقط بالوعيد بانها ستكبح
محاولات ايران لترسيخ وجودها العسكري في
سوريا طهران نفت بشكل قاطع ان يكون اي من
مواطنيها قد قتل او اصيب في الغارات
الاسرائيليه على دمشق مؤكده ان جميع من
قتلوا في كفر سوسهم سوريون منذ ما يقرب من
عشره اعوام شنا الجيش الاسرائيلي مئات
الضربات الجويه في سوريا تستهدف مواقع
للجيش السوري واهدافا ايرانيه واخرى لحزب
الله بينها مستودعات اسلحه وذخائر يقول
خبراء عسكريون اسرائيليون ان الغارات
الجويه جزء من تصعيد بصراع منخفض الحده
هدفه ابطاء الوجود العسكري المتنامي
لايران في سوريا
اسرائيل اذا لم تعلق على الهجوم لكن رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامنه ياهو قال في
حديث له امس ان اسرائيل لن تسمح لايران
بامتلاك سلاح النووي او التمركز قرب حدود
اسرائيل الشماليه حسب قوله
لن نسمح لايران بامتلاك سلاح نووي ولن
نتيح لها التمركز قرب حدودنا الشماليه
نفعل كل شيء لحمايه مواطنين ونرد بقوه على
الهجمات ضدنا
ابلغت مجلس الامن الدولي انها لن تدعو
للتصويت على مشروع قرار يطالب اسرائيل
بوقت ثوري وكامل لجميع الانشطه
الاستيطانيه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله واوضحت الوكاله ان الامارات ارسلت
مذكره للدول الاعضاء في مجلس الامن ذكرت
فيها انها تعكف حاليا على صياغه بيان رسمي
يسمى البيان الرئاسي يتعين على المجلس
الموافقه عليه بالاجماع وكانت الامارات قد
وزعت الاربعاء الماضي نص قرار على الدول
الاعضاء في مجلس الامن كانت قد صاغته
بتنسيق مع الفلسطينيين وجاءت هذه الخطوه
بعد ان اصدرت حكومه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
تراخيص لتسع بؤر استيطانيه عشوائيه واعلنت
بناء الاف الوحدات في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله
وقال مندوبه فلسطين في الامم المتحده رياض
منصور ان رئيس مجلس الامن سيتلو اليوم
بيانا اليوم الاثنين بخصوص مشروع القرار
الذي قدمته دوله الامارات باسم فلسطين
لادانه المشروع الاستيطانيه التوسعي
الاسرائيلي الجديد وامتنع منصور عن نفي او
تاكيد التوصل الى تفاهم ببساطه امريكيه
يقضي بعدول الجانب الفلسطيني عن طرح مشروع
القرار على مجلس الامن وذلك مقابل توقف
الحكومه الاسرائيليه عن تنفيذ مخططها
الاستيطانيه الذي اقرت الاسبوع الماضي
والكف عن هدم منازل الفلسطينيين وتشريدهم
وقال منصور ان بيان رئيس مجلس الامن سيكون
بالاتفاق مع الولايات المتحده وجميع
اعضائه الاربعه عشر وكان موقع وكاله ولا
الاخباريه الاسرائيليه الذين قال النباء
حول توصل للتفاهم قد نقل عن مسؤول
اسرائيلي كبير نف لذلك جمله وتفصيلا
معنى من لندن محمد العطيفي الكتب والمحلل
السياسي سيد محمد برايك اي الدلالات
يحملها سحب مشروع القرار الذي قامت به
الامارات
والذي يطالب اسرائيل بوقف الاستيطان يتم
سحبه وتعكس الامارات الان على صياغه بيان
لماذا ومدلالات هذه الخطوه
هو الى الان لم تتضح صحه هذه المعلومه لان
لو نظرنا الى حتى الولايات المتحده
والعديد من الدول الاوروبيه اصدر بيان
بادانه اسرائيل في بناء المستوطنات
وبالتالي العديد من الدول في تقف بحده
امام اسرائيل في مساله بناء المستوطنات
وبالتالي حتى عندما
عندما راينا الامارات كان لديها رؤيه في
ان يكون هناك قرار ادانه في مجلس الامن
بوقف الاستيطان وبالتالي يعني ما نرى
اليوم او هذا الخبر لم تؤكدوا العديد من
الجهات المسؤوله
لكن
واضح عفوا مندوب فلسطين في الامم المتحده
يقول ان رئيس اليوم بينا بخصوص مشروع
مشروع القرار هذا يعني بمعنى كما نقلت
وكاله رويترز يبدو انه لن يكون هناك تصويت
على على مشروع القانون الاول الذي كان
قدمت به الامارات ويبدو انه سحب
يعني انا لا استبعد ان ان تتم او ان يكون
هناك معالجه دبلوماسيه لكن في ظل
الوقفه الدوليه
بما فيها امريكا وحتى المجموعه الاوروبيه
فرنسا بريطانيا كلها كانت ضد القرار
الاسرائيلي ببناء المستوطنات
يعني لو نظرنا لموقف الامارات موقف
الامارات يعني اذا كان هناك شيء من هذا
القبيل معناه ان هناك تفاهم دبلوماسي من
الممكن ان يفضي الى الى ما سرب الان من ان
الامارات تراجعت عن الخطوه في ان تضع هذا
البرنامج او الورقه في مجلس الامن للتطوير
يعني استبدال مشروع القرار ببيان يتم
قبوله بالاجماع ولكنك انت الان اشرت بوضوح
الى هناك يعني حتى الدول الغربيه بكاملها
ادانت خطوه الاستيطان وبالتالي هذا الزخم
الا يجب ان يستثمر بمشروع قرار داخل مجلس
الامن ووضع هذه الدول امام
بحكم مصداقيتها بان توافق عليه
لو نزلنا الى الامارات وجدنا الى موقف
الامارات كان واضح في اكثر من موقف تجاه
التعنت الاسرائيلي يعني لو نظرنا مثلا في
زياره بنجافير الى الاقصى كان هناك وقفه
الامارات قالت ان هذا خطا ويجب ان يوضع في
الاعتبار وعلى الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان
تراعي هذه النقاط التي من الممكن ان تؤدي
الى تراجع في موقفها مع الدول العربيه
التي تقيم معها علاقات
لو نظرنا يعني حتى المستقبل ربما يفهم
تطبيق عدد اخرى عدد من الدول الاخرى مع
اسرائيل فاسرائيل عليها ان تتفاهم هذه
النقطه ويجب يعني لذلك انا انا ارى من
المستبعد ان يتم سحب
المذكره التي تريد ان تتوجه بها الامارات
الى الامم المتحده اما مساله ما نراه او
او نحن نتحدث عن دبلوماسيه وفي
الدبلوماسيه كل
اتضحت الفكره السيد محمد العطيفي الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي من لندن
ومن رام الله معنا مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
العمله المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه سيد
مصطفى مرحبا
بالتعليقك على هذا الخبر
المتعلق بسحب مشروع القرار الذي سبق ان
قدمته الامارات بالتعاون او بالتنسيق مع
الفلسطينيين لادانه الاستيطان الاسرائيلي
اولا الذي قدم مشروع القرار هو من
فلسطينيون طبعا
في مجلس الامن لطرحه
نحن ضد سحب هذا القرار باي حاله من
الاحوال
ونطالب السلطه الفلسطينيه بان لا توظف لاي
ضغوط امريكيه او غير امريكيه لسحب هذا
القرار لانه سحب القرار واستبداله ببيان
يجعله طبعا اضعف بكثير وغير الزامي وسحب
القرار سيكون فقط محاوله
لفتح المجال امام الولايات المتحده لتخرج
من الحرج الذي كانت ستواجهه باستخدام حق
النقد الفيتو ضد قرار يطالب بوقف
الاستيطان الذي تدعي انها ضده لا يجوز
التراجع لانه حسب تسرب من انباء ان
التراجع سيتم مقابل ان لا تقوم اسرائيل
باقرار خطط جديده ولكن اسرائيل اعلنت عن
13 مستوطنه استعماريه جديده خطير جدا هاي
اول مره يتم الاعلان عن مستوطنات جديده
منذ عقود واسرائيل اعلنت انها تنوي هدم
الاف المنازل واقرت بناء عشر الاف وحده
استيطانيه وقف مخططات جديده اصلا المخططات
الجديده لن تبحث الا بعد ثلاثه شهور اذا
اسرائيل تحصل على هروب من اتخاذ قرار في
مجلس الامن مقابل لا شيء في الواقع وهذه
خدعه كبرى خدعه مره اخرى يجري التخطيط لها
لذلك نحن نقول انه يجب رفض سحب القرار باي
حاله من الاحوال ويجب عدم السماح للولايات
المتحده بان تهرب من الحرج هم يواصلوا
الحديث عن حل الدولتين كلاميا وهم يرون
اسرائيل تذبح حل الدولتين بالاستيطان ولا
يمارس اي اجراء عقابه ضدها طيب لكن هنا
للاشاره ان الامارات عندما قدمت المشروع
قدمته باعتبارها تراس المجموعه العربيه
يعني
رسميا هي قدمت
المشروع القرار بتنسيق مع الفلسطينيين
بطلب من الفلسطينيين لكن رسميا هي التي
التي قدمته طيب لماذا لا يكون هنا ان
الامارات تريد ان تتفادى اسقاط المشروع
بالفيتو الامريكي بغض النظر عن الاحراج
لكن يصبح كانه لم يكن في حين ان بيانا
يقبله الجميع ربما
يعني
يطالب او تطالب به اسرائيل اكثر من قرار
ساقط اساسا في في مجلس الامن
اولا مجلس الامن اخذ اصلا وسابقا قرارا لم
تفوت الى جانبه الولايات المتحده ولكن
امتنعت عن التصويت يدين الاستيطان ويطالب
بوقفه في اخر عهد اوباما
وبعد ذلك يعني لم يصدر اي قرار اخر حتى لو
لم يصدر قرار جديد هناك قرار صدر بوقف
الاستيطان لكن التحدي هنا الاساسي ان
الولايات المتحده والدول الغربيه التي
تقول انها معك حل الدولتين كما تدعي ومع
قيام دوله فلسطينيه مستقله تصمت ولا تتخذ
اي اجراءات عقابيه على ذبح ما يسمى بحل
الدولتين على الاستيطان المستشري الذي
تقول انه يقضي على حده الدولتين وهو في
الواقع تضع على حل الدولتين يعني هي
محاوله للهروب من اجراءات عقابيه نقطه
ثانيه حسب ما فهمنا او ما تسرب ان البيان
انصدر سيتضمن ايضا ادانات للجانب
الفلسطيني والضد
النضال الوطني الفلسطيني وهذا طبعا امر
مرفوض المساواه بين الطرفين طرف معتدي
وطرف محتل وطرف تحت الاحتلال ويمارس ضد
نظام الابارتين في جميع الاحوال البعض
يقول انه لا يريد اشكال المقاومه الاخرى
ويريد ان يركز على المقاومه السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه طب لماذا يسحب القرار حتى
المقاومه الدبلوماسيه ممنوعه حتى المقاومه
بمشاريع القانون الدولي ممنوعه هذا كلام
غير صحيح وفي غير مكانه لذلك نحن ندعو
ونطالب السلطه الفلسطينيه بان لا تسمع
بسحب القرار وان تستمر به الى النهايه
مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره
الوطنيه
حدثنا من رام الله
[موسيقى]
قال الامين العمله الاتحاد التونسي للشغل
نور الدين الطبوبي ان تونس لا يمكن ان
تبني بخطاب الكراهيه ان تبنى بخطاب
الكراهيه والاتهامات وان التي حدا مستهدف
لانه قال كلمته بشكل واضح وهو مستعد
لمواجهه الهجمه التي يريد البعض انتهاجها
لتمرير مشاريع بيع مكاسب البلاد حسب
تعبيره واوضح الطبوب ان الاتحاد لن يقف
محايدا دون الدفاع عن الحريات النقابيه
والفرديه والعامه وقال ان حضور الامينه
العامه لاتحاد النقابات الاوروبيه
للتحركات النقابيه في تونس كان رساله دعم
ومسانده وليس كما روج بانه استقواء
بالاجنبي واضاف الطبوب ان الاتحاد لا
يستقوي باحد وسيبقى صامدا رغم ما يمارس
ضده من شي وتشوين وثبركه ملفات ضده مثل ما
حدث في الستينيات والسبعينيات
والثمانينيات حسب قوله
[موسيقى]
اختتمت القمه الافريقيه بالتصديق على
البيان الختامي الذي تضمن ابرز المشروعات
والقرارات المرفوعه للقمه من قبل المجلس
الوزاري تناول البيان الختامي قضايا
اقتصاديه وسياسيه وامنيه عده ابرزها تسريع
تفعيل منطقه التجاره الحره الافريقيه
ومبادره اسكات البنادق لتسويه الصراعات في
اطار افريقي ودعم عمليات التحول
الديمقراطي ورفض الانقلابات العسكريه وعدم
الاعتراف بالانظمه القائمه عليها كما اشار
رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي الى اولويه
مشروع منطقه التجاره الحره مؤكدا ان عددا
من الدول بدات بالفعل مرحله التنفيذ
ونفى موسى فيك رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي قيام المفوضيه بتقديم دعوه
لاسرائيل لحضور القمه الافريقيه واضاف في
رده على سؤال لمراسل الجزيره خلال مؤتمر
الصحفي الختامي للقمه الافريقيه ان مساله
حضور الوفد الاسرائيلي قيد التحقيق الان
وان الوضع القانوني بشان قبول اسرائيل
كعضو مراقب بالاتحاد معلق لحين بتل لجنه
السبعه التي شكلت العمل الماضي لهذا الغرض
ناقشنا العمل الماضي وضعه اسرائيل كمراقب
في الاتحاد الافريقي وبعد هذه النقاشات
المختلفه قرر المؤتمر تشكيله من رؤساء
الدول للبت في هذه المساله وهذا يعني ان
الوضع القانوني معلق حتى تفصل فيه هذه
اللجنه وبالتالي لم ندعم مسؤولين رسميين
اسرائيليين الى قمتنا لاحظنا وجود شخصيه
دخلت القاعه ببطاقه دخول وطالبناها
بمغادره المكان ونحن نقوم بالتحقيقات
الضروريه لانها شخصيه لا تقيم هنا وجاءت
من اسرائيل ولا يمكن ان يصل احد الى هنا
الا بدعوه من رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي ونحن لم ندعو اي مسؤول ولاحظنا
ما حدث وسنقوم بالتحقيق لتحديد المسؤوليات
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن انه اكد لنظيره الصيني ان بلاده لن
تقف مكتوفه الايدي امام انتهاك سيادتها في
اشاره لازمه امتاض التجسس من جهتها حذرت
الصين واشنطن من انها ستتحمل كل العواقب
اذا وصلت التصعيد بشان المنطاد الصينيه
الذي اسقطه الجيش الامريكي في الرابع من
فبراير شباط الجاري جاء ذلك بعد اول لقاء
بين بلينك ونظيره الصيني منذ اندلاع ازمه
المنطاد الصيني
معنى من واشنطن الدكتور ريتشارد وايت رئيس
قسم دراسات الصين في معهد هيدسون وان لندن
مع ناديه الصحفيه الصيني ومدير مكتب لندن
في شبكه فينكس الاعلاميه الصينيه سيد
ريتشارد نبدا معك وما هي العواقب التي
ستواجهها الصين والتي
حذر منها وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
لقد تحدث بطريقه ضبابيه عمدا حيث ان
الولايات المتحده حاولت ان تقدم للصين في
السابق الفرصه بان يكون لديها قدره على
الوصول الى الاقتصادات الاوروبيه
والامريكيه او الاقتصاد الروسي الصين
لديها علاقات تجاريه اكثر بكثير مع اوروبا
ومع الولات المتحده الامريكيه وهذا ما ادى
الى محدوديه التعاون الاقتصادي والعسكري
بين الصين وروسيا على الارجح هذه افضل
اداه لدى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
العقوبات الاقتصاديه لمنع تعاون مماثل بين
الصين وروسيا طيب وايضا فيما يتعلق بقول
بلينكن ان الولايات المتحده لن تقف مكتوفه
الايدي امام انتهاك
ما الذي ستفعله وقد تابعنا جميعا تفاعلات
قضيه المنطاد الصيني هل انتهى الامر عند
اسقاطه بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اشارت
انها تعتزم
اسقاط اي بلاطيه اضافيه تدخل المجال الجوي
الامريكي ويقدر انها لاغراض التجسس اذا
بحسب رايي الامر انتهى والصين قالت انها
سوف تتصرف بنفس الطريقه اذا ما رات مناطيد
امريكيه فوق الصين والان التركيز اصبح على
روسيا
اذا كما فهمنا من ضيفنا من الولايات
المتحده التركيز الان على روسيا لكن
العواقب انما هي عواقب لها علاقه
بعقوبات اقتصاديه الى اي مدى
بامكان الصين ان تواجه التهديد بعقوبات
اقتصاديه امريكيه وغربيه بشكل عام
نعم اعتقد ان الامر يرتبط بازمه المنطاد
ازمه المنطاد هي التي ادت الى هذه المساله
الجدليه بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والصين ولكن اللقاء بين وزيري الخارجيه في
ميونخ هو النقطه جيده هذا يعني ان كلا
الطرفين يودان ان يتحدث مع بعضهما البعض
والحوار مستمر بين
الاقتصادين الاكبر في العالم بالنسبه الى
موضوع العقوبات وفرضي العقوبات على الصين
هذا موضوع يخضع للتفاوض وهو موضوع سياسي
لان اي اي عقوبات اقتصاديه هي عباره عن
سيف ذي حدين
الحكومه الامريكيه قد اتخذت قرارات
بشان شركات صينيه بعد ازمه المنطاد اعتقد
ان اداره الرئيس بايدن قبل
الانتخابات المقبله تود ان تظهر انها
لديها سياسات متشدده تجاه الصين هذا امر
للاستهلاك السياسي الداخلي الامريكي
بالنسبه الى السياسه العامه انا متفائل
بشان العلاقات الثنائيه بين الصين
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
البلدان يودان ان يتخاطباء
ويتحاوراه وهذا ما شاهدناه في ميونخ وتم
تسليط الضوء على مسالتين العلاقه بين
الصين والولايات المتحده والمساله الثانيه
هي الحرب بين روسيا
طيب ولكن سيده ساو عفوا عفوا ولكن هناك
تحذير امريكي
هناك تحذير امريكي للصين من مغبه مساعده
روسيا بشكل مباشر في الحرب على اوكرانيا
باختصار كيف ستتصرف في الصين اذا اذلك
[موسيقى]
في الحقيقه نحن لم نرى اي ادله حول
مساعدتي الصين
روسيا من خلال ابدادها
بالبواد والعتاد
على المستوى العسكري اذا هناك
علاقه بين الصين وروسيا وهناك علاقه ايضا
بين الصين واوكرانيا اعلنت الحكومه
الصينيه منذ اسابيع انها سوف تقدم
المساعده لاوكرانيا وليس روسيا
الحكومه الصينيه نعم
اعربت عن موقفا واضح تجاه هذه الحرب شكرا
لك
وحدثتنا من لندن وشكرا ريتشارد كان معنا
من واشنطن
تباينت مواقف قاده المكون العسكري
السوداني تجاه العمليه السياسيه فبينما
اعلن قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
حميدتي دعمه المطلق للاتفاق الايطالي
رهن قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان دعمه
للاتفاق بتوسيع قاعدته ودمج قوات الدعم
السريع في الجيش
تبين واضح في التصريحات بين عبد الفتاح
البرهان ونائبه محمد حمدان حميتي التباين
يدور حول الاتفاق الايطالي ووضع قوات
الدعم السريع وقررت البرهان في الخامس
والعشرين من اكتوبر عام 2021
اعلن صراحه دعمه للاتفاق الايطالي الموقع
بين قوى مدنيه ابرزها قوى الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي والمكون العسكري بصيغه
الراهنه محذرا من فتح الباب امام عوده
عناصر النظام المعزول للحكم خطا انقلاب 25
اكتوبر ليصبح للاسف بوابه لعوده النظام
البائد مما دفعني لعدم التردد بان اعود
عنه الى الصواب بان هذه العمليه السياسيه
قد تطاول زمنها
وان الوقت قد حان لانهائها والوصول لحل
سياسي نهائي
لكن رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
شدد في وقت سابق على ان دعم الجيش للاتفاق
الايطالي يكون وفق رؤيه الجيش وهو مرهون
بتنفيذ بند دمج قوات الدعم السريع داخل
الجيش
حرب التصري كما يصفه البعض هنا بين
المسؤولين العسكريين تصل الى مرحله
التحذير من ان التراجع عن الاتفاق
الايطالي قد يؤدي الى تقسيم البلاد
بينما يرى اخرون في مجلس السياده ان القوه
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي غير كافيه
لحل الازمه السياسيه في البلاد وينادون
بفتح الباب لضم اطراف اخرى وهذا الصراع هو
صراع قياده وليس صراع قاعده وبالتالي
ينتهي في تقدير بانتهاء مرحله التسويه
وتحديد مكان الرجلين من العمليه السياسيه
الحاليه التي تدور في السودان حاله من
الشد والجذب وتصريحات متباينه بين العسكر
قد تزيد من تعقيدات المشهد في البلاد التي
تعاني هشاشه امنيه الوقت صاديه يصعب
التكهن بما الاتاتها الطهر المرضي الجزيره
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا مع تخطي حصيته سته واربعين الف
قتيل من بينهم اكثر من اربعين الفا في
تركيا يصبح الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
في السادس من فبراير من الزلازل العشره
الاشد والاكثر فتكا خلال المئه عام
الاخيره في عام
1976 اتزلزل بقوه سبع درجات فاصل ثمانيه
بحسب السلطات الصينيه او سبع درجات فاصل
خمسه وفق المركز الامريكي للمسح الجيولوجي
على مدينه تندشن الصناعيه الواقعه على بعد
200 كيلومتر شرط بيجين بلغت الحصيله
الرسميه 200 و 242 الف قتيل غير ان
تقديرات خبراء غربيين تصل الى 700 الف
قتيل
في 26 ديسمبر
2004 زلزال بقوه التسع درجات وعشره درجه
قباله سواحل سومطره في اندونيسيا ادى الى
مد زلزالي او تسنمي هائل اوقع اكثر من 230
الف قتيل على سواحل عشره بلدان من جنوب
شرق اسيا بينهم 170 الفا في اندونيسيا
وحدها في ثاني عشر من يناير عام 2010 ادى
زلزال بقوه سبع درجات في هيئه الى سقوط
اكثر من
1200 الف قتيل وتشريد مليون و500 الف شخص
وحول العاصمه بوور
اوبرنس حولها الى انقاض
في الاول من سبتمبر عام
1923 قرابه الظهر قرابه الظهر هز زلزالون
بقوه سبع درجات فاصل تسعه سهل كانتو في
اليابان واوداء بحياه اكثر من 142 الف شخص
فضلا عن 100 الف جريح قضى معظمهم او
اصيبوا بحرائق اجتاحت طوكيو ويوكو هاما
على مدى يومين في الثاني عشر من مايو عام
2008 تسبب زلزال بقوه سبع درجات فاصل تسعه
بسقوط اكثر من 87 الف قتيل ونحو اربعه
ملايين وخمسمائه الف مصاب وذلك في مناطق
شاسعه من محافظه سيشوان بجنوب غرب الصين
وكان بين الضحايا الاف التلاميذ الذين
قضوا جراء انهيار مدارس سيئه البناء عليهم
معنى من روما البروفيسور كارلو غليوني
رئيس المعهد الوطني الايطاليه للجيو
فيزياء والبراكين سيد كارلوس هل تقاس شده
او قوه هذه الزلازل واعتبارها من من اقوى
الزلازل هل تقاس بعدد الضحايا او المناطق
او اتساع المناطق التي دمرتها
في الحقيقه ان الزلازل تقاس اولا
لجهه قوتها بمعنى الطاقه التي تنبعث وبعد
ذلك الامر يتوقف على المخاطر الاخرى
المرتبطه
بالزلزال اذا هنا يمكننا ان نتحدث عن
هشاشه المباني على سبيل المثال وبعض
الزلازل التي حصلت في السابق واشرت اليها
في اندونيسيا في العام 2004
ادى هذا الزلزال الى اكثر من 200 الف ضحيه
او ايضا الزلزال الاخر في هايتي وهو كان
اقل قوه بالمقارنه مع الزلزال في تركيا
وهذا الى اكثر من 200 الف قتيل وهذا
بالتحديد ما كنت اود ان ان اسال عنه
يعني
عند اي درجه يمكن ان نعتبر ان الزلزال
اصبح مدمرا هلا قد يكون مدمرا على خمس
درجات اذا كانت الابنيه هشه جدا ولكن
بالمنظار العلمي عند اي درجه يكون الزلزال
مدمرا بالفعل
بالنسبه الى قوه الزلزال
يمكننا ان نقول ان كل البنى التحتيه
دمرت وكل البشر الذين هم في المباني قضوا
اولاقه حتفهم اذا هذا
زلزال مدمر للغايه ولكن نبدا في البدايه
عن او بموضوع دراسه الطاقه
وعند ذلك
يتم اتخاذ القرار هل الناس الذين يعيشون
في منطقه معينه يمكنهم ان يصمدوا امام هذه
الطاقه المنبعثه من الارض الارض عندما
تتحرك هناك تاثير من الاسفل الى السطح
ويمكننا ان نرى المباني تتهاوى اذا
المنطقه التي يجب ان نبدا بدراستها هي
مركز الزلزال وهناك في هذه النقطه تهتز
الارض باكبر قدر ممكن وهذا يؤدي الى الحاق
الضرر بالمباني
لماذا اعتبر زلزال تركيا وسوريا هو من من
الزلازل العشره شده في القرن الاخير لماذا
هذا غير صحيح حيث انه اذا ما تحدثنا عن
الطاقه
ليس من بين اشد نعم طبعا نحن نتحدث عن
ماساه فظيعه لجهه عدد الضحايا ولكن اذا ما
كنا نتحدث عن الطاقه المنبعثه اذا يمكننا
ان نتحدث عن زلزال طوكيو على سبيل المثال
وزلزال الصين
والزلزال اندونيسيا اذا هذه الزلازل
المتعدده كانت قويه للغايه وبالتالي الامر
يتوقف عن طريقه تقييمنا هل نتحدث عن
الطاقه طاقه الزلزال او عدد الناس الذين
تاثروا او قدروا ولكن عاده يكون لدينا
عشره زلازل بين سبعه وسبعه فاصله تسعه في
العالم تضرب شتى العالم شكرا جزيلا لك
البروفيسور كارلو ديغولي رئيس المعهد
الوطني الايطاليه للجيو فيزياء والبراكين
[موسيقى]
مره اسبوعان على كارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا ولا تزال جهود المسعفين
مستمره والمهمه هي انقاذ كل حياه تحت
الانقاض تمت حكايات كثيره عن ناجين من
البشر ينتظرون ناجين من غير البشر الارقام
تشير الى ان فرق جمعيه هيتاب التركيه
لحمايه الحيوانات تمكنت من انقاذ 900
حيوان من قطط وكلاب وارانب وابقار وطيور
من انقاذ انطاكيا جنوبي تركيا بينما اتصل
اصحاب هذه الحيوانات بالجمعيه بعدم قدرتهم
على انت
وفي ثنايا القصص يقول اطباء ومسعفون ان
الكلاب او القطط التي علقت تحت الانقاض
تمكنت من الوصول الى طعام او ثلاجات وهو
ما سمح لها بالصمود فتره اطول هي محنه
للجميع والامل كل الامل ان تكتب النجاه
منها للبشر وغير البشر ايضا
واصل التغطيه بعد
موجز
رياضيا مع معز بولحيه
[موسيقى]
ارحب بكم في جوله اخبار الرياضه نبدا من
انجلترا ماركوس راشفورد قادما مانشستر
يونايتد لانتصار عريض ومهم امام ليستر
سيتي بثلاثه اهداف دون مقابل على ملعب
اولترافورد وذلك ضمن الاسبوع الرابع
والعشرين من الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز
لكره القدم ينعش اليونايتد اماله مره اخرى
في المنافسه على اللقب
في وسط الميدان لمصلحه فريق اليونايتد
الحارس الاسباني كان نجم الشوط الاول من
مباراه فريقه مانشستر يونايتد امام الضيفه
ليستوستي فقد حرم هارفي من هدف السابق
واصلا ديخيه تالقه اللافت حافظا على نظافه
شباك
الثعالب استفز قدرات مانيونايتد فشدد
الضغط على مرمى من كره اولى نجح ماركوس
راشفورد في افتتاح النتيجه للشياطين الحمر
بحلول الدقيقه الخامسه والعشرين
منح هذا الهدف افضليه لمان يونايتد الذي
كان قريبا من مضاعفه النتيجه الاولى
العارضه
يحلول الدقيقه 56 واصل توهجه محليا وقاريا
واضف الهدف الثاني لفريقه هم ما جعله
يحتفل بهدف الرابع والعشرين في مختلف
المسابقات
[تصفيق]
اصبحت مثاليه جيدا
لتدوين اسمه بين المسجلين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قد اختتم ثلاثيه المان يونايتد كما رفع
رصيده فريقه الى 49 نقطه في المركز الثالث
مؤكدا انه سيكون احد الفرسان المنافسين
على اللقب في انتظار ملاكه الجدد
سنبقى ضمن الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز
توتنهام تغلب على ويست هام يونايتد بهدفين
دون مقابل افتتح المدافع البرازيلي
اميرسون التسجيل لتوتنهام في الدقيقه
السادسه والخمسين
واضاف بعد ذلك الكوري الجنوبي من صون هدفا
ثانيا لاصحاب الارض في هذا الفوز رفعه
تتنمر سيده الاثنتين
واربعين نقطه في المركز الرابع
والهدف الثاني لفريق توتنهام
[تصفيق]
الى فرنسا الان باريس سان جيرمان حقق فوزا
مثيرا على الليل باربعه اهداف لثلاث على
واحده من ابرز مباريات الاسبوع الرابع
والعشرين من الدوري الفرنسي لكره القدم
خمسه واربعون يوما باريس سان جيرمان بخمس
هزائم محليا وقاريه تلك النتائج ادخلت
المدرب غالتي مرحله الشك لكن الثالوث
الهجومي لحامل اللقب حاول تخفيف الضغوط عن
مدربه
[تصفيق]
مره اخرى فقد اضاع ميسي الفرصه الاولى
بعدها بدقائق نجح مبابي في هز شباك الضيف
ليل بحلول الدقيقه الحاديه عشره
وكانت ست دقائق اخرى كافيه امام البرازيلي
نيمار لمضاعفه النتيجه
[موسيقى]
كره القدم
اشتغلت دفاعيه من فريق العاصمه وقلص
الفارق لمصلحه له
المميزه الله
تلقى المدرب غالتي ضربه موجعه بخروج
البرتغالي نونو منديش مصابا ولان المصائب
لا تاتي فرادى فقد تجدد كابوس الاصابات مع
نيمار ليخسر غلطي لاعبا اخر من التشكيله
الاساسيه قبل فتره مزدحمه من المباريات
وازدادت المتاعب للفارسيين بعد احتساب
الحكم ركله جزاء لمصلحه ليل ترجمها الى
هدف التعادل يتقدم
الله القلق بدا واضحا على المدرب غالتي
الذي تلقت شباكه هدفا ثالثا بواسطه بامبا
فرصه قائمه تسديد الله
[موسيقى]
عندما يوجد مبابي فان الاهداف تبدو قريبا
وهو ما حدث اذ تمكن من تسجيل هدف التعادل
الله الله
[موسيقى]
الضلع الثالث من الثالث الهجومي ليونيل
ميسي الا ان يترك بصمته في المباراه اذ
خطف هدف الفوز المثير لباريس سان جيرمان
مانحا مدربه قبله الحياه
كذلك منذ قليل مارسيليا عزيزه مركزه
الثاني تغلب على تولوز بثلاثه اهداف
لهدفين تولوز ومن بادر بالتهديف عن طريق
دالينكا وانتظر مارسيليا الشوط الثاني
لتعديل الكف عن طريق بيمبا وذلك في
الدقيقه الثانيه والخمسين وضعف نتيجه
لمارسيليا في الدقيقه التاسعه والخمسين
اختتم تفاريست ثلاثيه فريق الجنوب في
الدقيقه الثامنه والسبعين من عمر هذه
المباراه تروس تمكن من تسجيل هدف ثان عبر
اونايو في الدقيقه 87 لتنتهي المباراه
بثلاثه اهداف بهدفين
هدف ولا اروع منذ قليل ايضا برشلونه عزز
الصداره في اسبانيا تغلب على قادش بهدفين
دون مقابل في الاسبوع الثاني والعشرين
سيرجي روبيرتو سجل هدف السابق للبارصا في
الدقيقه الثالثه والاربعين قبل نهايه
الشوط الاول البولندي روبرت ليفاندوفسكي
ضعف النتيجه
للبارصا لانتصار هو السابعه على التوالي
لبرشلونه رفع رصيده 59 نقطه بفارق ثمان
نقاط عن ريال مدريد
وحيدا فقط التغلب ايضا قتيكو مدريد على
ضيف اتلتيكو بلباو بهدف من دون مقابل هدف
حمل توقيع الفرنسي انطوان غريزمان عند
الدقيقه الثالثه والسبعين
في اسبانيا كذلك اشبيليه تعادل مع
الرايكانو بهدف بمثله
في الدقيقه 29 دقيقه
ادرك لوجون التعادل برايو
في المانيا بروسيا دورتموند عزز الموقع
الثاني في الدوري الالماني حقق فوزان
السادس عن التوالي تغلب على هيرتا برلين
باربعه اهداف لهدف في واحده ايضا من ابرز
مباريات الاسبوع الحادي والعشرين
للروس
يه يتقدم الرئيس الس
ابق كره مش
كريم بالكاف كريم ينطلق يريد خطير خطير
الثاني والهدم الثاني
الهدف عن طريق انفوان الشباب
من خلال اللاعب ان كان كام خطير يرتبط
هدف لصالح مارك
انطلاقه
مشروع الرابع وال
رابع الانجليزي الرهيب
اشتم هديه للشاب ختام الجوله الرياضيه
المسائيه الموجزه الان الى عبد القادر
[موسيقى]